okay so on the on the topic of materials
and see this is what i'm talking about
right um
this is my brush is too thick it's a
disaster
on the topic of my materials these this
these kind of streams are exactly what
i'm talking about like
this would be way too ridiculous to put
into a video because it's gonna take
hours but
um it's nice to uh just hang out with
the stream and do this stuff and i think
people who want this content can watch
it
themselves on twitch or on youtube if
they're a patreon so
um it's gonna be fun it's gonna be okay
people who like this stuff you'll still
get it
so basically um
uh the way this is gonna work the most
important thing for materials are
let's start with the definition of
materials right so what are materials
so the way that we usually think of a
material
is i would say um
it's consistent with three pieces of
data but really what is a material a
material is something that describes how
we render something
right so how do we render an object
what does it look like that's really
what it is
right so there are three components to
this
there is a shader which of course is the
actual code that rasterizes
our pixels right i mean also can uh
position our vertices like you would say
you could have a material that
makes something wavy um you know and
actually transforms vertices and
does more than just position them in the
world correctly
um so you could do that but mostly we we
kind of talk about
pixel shaders and you know a way to
actually
um you know write code that calculates
lighting and does various other things
to determine the final
color of that a pixel as it gets
rasterized so the shader
um the shader but then also the data so
we'll say
shader data
so the shaded data is basically
uniforms
plus textures which we kind of consider
as uniforms anyway
um so uniforms and textures
is kind of what makes up the data inside
our shader we can store other things
inside
shaders but usually those things
um like you for example uniform buffers
usually we wouldn't have a uniform
buffer for the material
because the uniform buffer is something
that like the renderer would maintain
um not nothing really with material the
same way as like
the transform matrix you know your
transform matrix would not really be
part of your material
um because we're more or less describing
the look of this not
rendering intrinsic kind of internal
things like where does this object go on
the scene
and then finally we uh have other kind
of
other information that determines how it
gets rendered
so these are basically we usually
consider these properties or flags
right and um these flags
basically determine uh well an example
of a flag would be something like
two-sided
[Music]
so is this let's say example
so is this material two-sided should i
render this with culling backface
calling disabled
right um is this uh should this be depth
tested
or should this write to the depth buffer
right stuff like that this is what i
mean by flags
um blending as well what kind of blend
mode should i use for this material
this kind of stuff this is what a
material actually is
right
pipeline state what do you mean by
pipeline state
what what kind of pipeline state
anyway
[Music]
so um
that's kind of what materials are and so
because of that we kind of have an
interesting little
uh problem to solve here oh the flags
answer it okay cool
um what well yeah that's what i was
thinking
i just thought maybe there was some
specific pipeline state that i missed
anyway um so how do we then
um you know populate this material with
data
like namely a shader is easy we can
provide a shader that's no problem
flags we can provide flags as well it's
just a bit field usually
like it's fine right but what about this
specifically how do we know when we
have a shader how do we know its
associated
data so how do we know hey what textures
does it require what uniforms does it
have
can i set a particular uniform can i not
set a particular uniform
and if i do how do i provide a nice api
for this
now at its core you don't need to know
anything about the shader
right at its core opengl lets us set
uniforms extremely
arbitrarily we can just bind
any program or in fact we don't even
have to bind a program we can just uh do
like gl
i don't know what is it program i think
gl program uniform
we give the uh shader id
sorry i know my face cam is in the way
we give the
shader id um
the location of the uniform which we can
maybe recreate from a name
so we'll say like you underscore color
right and then we give it the value
so for example 0.8
i don't know right
[Music]
and that's kind of it so we can
arbitrarily
we can arbitrarily set any uniform we
want
that's really easy to do in opengl you
know in vulcan things are a little bit
more robust we'll say but in opengl it's
very very clear that it's easy to do
right what that means is that
technically
we could get away with just
[Music]
basically bringing this burden of like
because okay
so what's the real variable here right
what's my goal why do i want to run this
code
the reason i want to run this code right
is more or less just simply because i
want to be able to
set this data into here right but let's
go even higher level
i want to set the color of my object
okay what does it mean to set the color
of my object well
usually to us that means that i want to
set a uniform with a particular name to
a particular value
the problem with this line here is that
there
is no validation whatsoever
right if i forget the underscore if i
spell color
the australian slash canadian slash
basically not the american way we'll say
that it's easier
if i spell color with a u like that
right um
this will not work this will crash most
likely it will
probably won't crash like because the
location will get back will be negative
one and
you know it will um maybe the debug
layer will
alert you to it but if you don't have
that then whatever you might just not
set it you might end up with a black
screen or a black object
whereas you wanted a gray one with lack
of blue
um you know
yeah i'm not really a big fan of this
track let me change it probably
interfering with my explanation
all right you know
so um at the end of the day my point
here with this is that
this is a bit as i like to call it
dogecoin
meaning it's dodgy i just say dogecoin
for fun
um so not great
right because there's no validation but
additionally
additionally it's not enough for me to
basically be like hey shader um
i would like to set the you underscore
color uniform is that a thing
right because the thing is is it a thing
it might be might not be it's relatively
easy for us to
basically you know pull the shader to
probe the shader
and just be like hey shader you know
does um does
you color exist no
okay does you color exist
oh yes sweet i found it
that's garbage we don't want to do this
right we can still do this easily right
what we can't do easily which i would
like to do right which is why we're
talking about this whole problem in
in the first place right what i would
like to do
is i would love to actually be like hey
shader
right hey shader
what are your uniforms imagine that
what are your uniforms
do what are your uniforms oh you have a
uniform
called you color oh thanks for telling
me
that's the kind of world we want to live
in right we don't want to just
completely
be like hey um you know does this work
does that work no
i mean look i i'm i'm kind of giving you
an example that maybe
isn't necessarily realistic because
realistically you're probably not going
to probe it and be like hey does this
exist does that exist
what i'm saying is that that that's your
alternative basically right of course
you would probably just open the shader
read the shader see that there's a
uniform called you color and then
set that that's not a problem what is
the problem
is um uh the fact that we can't actually
get the list of uniforms from the shader
because that
that gives that opens up a whole world
of opportunity um and we kind of want
that so
for example if we can ask it or what all
the uniforms are
we have a much better mechanism for
actually storing that data inside our
material
because what we can do is when someone
creates a new material that's based on a
particular shader
right what we can actually do from there
will be what what we can gather from
that
is um hey shader what are your uniforms
oh cool you have 16 uniforms whatever
right what i'm gonna do is actually
create
cpu size so c plus plus size storage for
all of those uniforms in the form of a
contiguous
buffer right which we can call kind of
like a uniform buffer it's not like an
opengl uniform buffer
it's just a buffer of data on the on the
cpu right well
in the cpu ram um and this buffer of
data again
inside our shader if we had something
like you know uniform you color uniform
you
roughness you metalness you you know um
whatever else we wanted to have there
what we could actually do here
is we could um everything belongs to the
material though right because we have to
distinguish
some other things like we might have a
uniform called camera position but we
don't really want to put that into our
material
so we need a way to to also separate
that but then again camera position will
probably be inside a uniform buffer
because
it would be shared across many different
drawers whereas like
the color of something is probably going
to be on a per object basis so there are
a lot of kind of semantics and other
details
that we're not really discussing at this
point in time but it's still very um
important to kind of do it this way so
well to kind of think about it like in
terms of
this buffer it's probably more simple
anyway so what we want to do then is we
want to basically get a
get a list of all of those uniforms
which we can actually use to get active
uniform for that as well but the point
is what we want to do is we want to get
a list of these uniforms so that we can
basically
you know know how big they are right
create a buffer that's large enough to
contain them
and then also be able to easily look up
a uniform
and see where it is inside that buffer
and if we have information if we have
that kind of reflection data like for
example
you know we uh have a uniform called
ucolor and then maybe after that
so let's just say this is like a vec3
then maybe we have a float
after it that is um the roughness and
it's called you underscore roughness
if i know that this is the case and i
pack this tightly with my padding and
stuff then what i know is that like this
obviously takes up 12 bytes of memory
this is a four byte float
right so therefore um i can just be like
i want to set you roughness i can look
for a variable called you roughness i
can find it inside this buffer
it's going to be at an offset of 12
bytes into this buffer this is going to
be like let's just say this is there in
four byte blocks
it's going to be right here so then i
can write my data into it and then when
it comes time to actually
settle the uniforms i can iterate
through my uniform declarations
basically
and then i can be like oh look there's a
uniform new roughness is over here it's
a flow so it's four bytes so i'm just
going to grab four bytes at an offset of
12 bytes and then mem copied them and
well
set them into like gl program uniform
you know
one f or whatever it's called right done
so that's kind of how it works and that
obviously lets us pretty nicely just
store a nice
tightly packed buffer of memory here
instead of um
instead of actually having to go through
the process of like okay well how do we
store five different variables if we
don't know what they are
um it's just not gonna be as nice as
just throwing them kind of tightly
packed inside a buffer
like this so that's how that works
um now
um what's the next thing okay so
that gives us yeah sure so that gives us
all of our uniforms right
what about textures so textures are
essentially an open gl textures are
basically uniforms
um we have uniform sampler 2d whatever
right you
underscore texture um we set that using
program uniform one eye or just gel
uniform one eye um and uh
the way the texture slots usually work
in opengl opengl and what you want to do
with them
is you want to basically iterate through
all of your texture slots inside your
shader
and just set them to some descending
order right so i think you can have up
to 32 texture slots
so you basically go through all of your
samplers once you know the samples that
exist in the shader
and then you can be like all right um
let's set let's set the first one to
zero
let's set the first one a one let's set
the first one a two let's hit the second
oh
sorry the second one the third one's
true that whatever
um you guys get the point
um we're just kind of going down this
list and we're setting them the reason
is
we could not care less what they're set
to
if i have a sampler in my shader i do
not need to specifically set that
sampler to be
five you know because that's a
meaningless number to me
i don't care so we can
we can do that as soon as we compile the
shader we can just go through
all the samplers and set them in
ascending order from zero to whatever
however many samples we have
now what we do care about is when i say
i have a sampler inside my texture
right let's just say sampler 2d um
you underscore texture i know i'm kind
of over the thing but you guys can see
it anyway
um i have this sample 2d underscore
texture
i want to set you underscore texture
inside my material
to be a particular value so that means
that when i render it
i need to bind that texture so what i
have to do is i have to say hey
shader you underscore texture
what slot did you assign to that what
texture unit did you give it
when you did your gel uniform one eye
what number did you
shove in there oh number two oh cool
okay
so then what i'll do is when it's time
to actually bind this material for
rendering
i will bind whatever texture i assigned
inside my shader dial to
you underscore texture i will bind that
to slot 2
because your texture belongs in slot 2
in the shader so that's kind of the
relationship that we create there
right it's um it's not like we have to
set uniform one eye all the time
or you know deal with that we don't need
to do we only care about that at all
the shader will automatically set all of
the samplers to just whatever they need
to be
and we can ask the shader to just give
us the texture slot that belongs to a
particular
texture and then we know what slot to
bind into by doing something like gl
bind texture unit or whatever on earth
it is right
um all right
so um
where do the problems begin now
i'm a little bit rusty with all this new
opengl api is there a function that we
can use to get information about uniform
buffers
um
because the next thing i was going to uh
actually talk about is the fact that
when we move into vulcan things are
going to be a bit different
um because we don't have uniforms
involved
we have uniform buffers and we have push
constants
um and we'll probably have some other
things but those are the main ones
um i think you can enumerate all the
uniform blocks and get active beautiful
boxes
all right okay in your all uniform
blocks all right whatever
um the point is uh i'm thinking a little
bit more ahead here and i'm thinking
more about vulcan because vulcan's gonna
work differently it's gonna have
different things
but also here's the problem that i'm
dealing with we will probably never have
uniforms in opengl like directly the way
that they appear now
because again vulcan doesn't have them
and obviously
i have no desire to
um i have no desire to write my
uh shaders twice right so because we
don't want to write our shaders twice
ever right what we're gonna do instead
is
write our shaders in a
language that we can then kind of
transpile to anything we want
so in other words what's actually going
to happen eventually is we're going to
write our shaders in vulcan gls
now vulcan glsl is different to opengl
glsl
yes it is still glsl but vulcan has many
other things that open shield does not
support
such as push constants right and sets
and other things right
but my point is that all of this stuff
that we're kind of providing into
a uh all of this kind of stuff that
we're providing into
our um uniform like
you color right that will instead go
into a push constant so inside
a inside vulcan um i'm kind of running
out of space here
so inside vulcan um you know we'll have
our little
layout welcome sorry inside
of alcangila cell we'll have like layout
push constant
um uh i don't remember the exact syntax
layout push constant
and then we can basically just have a
buffer right and then we can have like
you know vect3
uh you know you underscore color or
whatever if we want
but here's the thing we can actually
give this a name
such as like you underscore material
right for example and then what will
happen is when we tell spur v
to cross compile this from vulcan glsl
to opengl so this is vulcan
let's write vunken
vulcan right
when we compile this into opengl
what actually happens to it is it just
becomes a struct right
it just becomes a basically uniform well
it becomes a struct right a struct
called like material i think we have to
give this a name as well
but anyway it becomes a struct called
material
um which contains that vect3
you underscore color
right and then we have a uniform
material
you materials which is the name that we
gave it
here right so in other words
our glsl code becomes compatible but
this just becomes a regular old uniform
which we then set now because of that
right
um the answer the thing is okay well
then do we whoa
well then do we really use oh that's
weird
um well then do we really use opengl gl
get active uniform and whatever to
work this out and the answer is no we
don't have to because for vulcan
we'll use something called spervy
reflect very reflect lets us actually
retrieve all the information we could
ever care about about
um in terms of uh our gls shaders
now it doesn't support free floating
uniforms because it's not really made
for opengl it's made for falcon
even though it can compile um open gel
code
um open glg lsl into an opengl binary
shader
right we haven't even talked about
binary shaders but
that's one not that important at the
moment so anyway long story short um
is uh what we can do right and this is
how hazeldev currently works in the
vulcan branch
we write our shaders like this in vulcan
mode because that's our primary kind of
api
right then what happens is we
compile this vulcan shader into spur v
right so we've compiled it into a spurvy
binary
then we take the spurvy binary and we
cross compile it into
an opengl shader so this actually
becomes glsl
text right then we take this and we
compile it into
a spervy opengl binary i'm not sure if
we can skip the text step or not
i don't really remember and maybe this
doesn't even happen i don't know maybe
i'm just lying
we'll see um but the point is it gets
compiled into an opengl spurvy
and then we just use gl like shader
binary or
binary shader or whatever to basically
get set that into open gel
but see here's the thing since
um spare reflect doesn't support this
we can't get information about this from
this binary but we can actually use this
binary which exists anyway because
remember the text gets compiled to
vulcan
um jlsl which doesn't require vulkan you
don't need the vulcan api installed you
can completely not depend on it you
still need spur v which we need anyway
right
um and it's very reflect so from that
vulcan binary right
all it because remember you're just
compiling by code here it's just a
compiler nothing to do with rendering or
the api it's just a compiler
so what you do then here is um since we
have this very binary we can
actually use pepe reflect on the vulcan
binary to get information about the
constant buffers which are the push
constants right
and once we do that well there's our
color
variable that we can easily inspect we
can see the type we can see the name we
can see the offset we can see
the size we can see anything we want to
possibly see about it if it's an array
we can see all the details about that
and we can actually still use this data
in our opengl rendering
to determine hey we need to create a
buffer with a variable called you color
inside it
right so that is the full thing
push constants are 128 bytes
um 256 maybe in some implementations but
it's 128 right
you can use dynamic uniform buffers and
other uniform buffers and maybe even
shader storage stuff for other things
but 128 bytes is actually not bad it's
just that
um problematically as far as i'm aware
it's pretty common to put your
transform matrix inside a push constant
which already takes up half of it
um which half because it's 64 bytes but
anyway it's been okay for us in hazel
dev so far
because that still leaves us with 64
bytes of actual values you know you're
not talking about
you you're not talking about textures or
anything right um and even like a vec 4
is at 16 bytes but
you know you can be you don't need that
much stuff you know
like for like you know you have a lot of
floats which are four bytes
you don't have that many vectors apart
from that color i don't know i haven't
had a
i haven't run out of space yet and if i
did i guess i would just use a uniform
buffer or a dynamic uniform buffer or
something like that
anyway whatever um so
um
yeah so uniform buffers remember we want
to use uniform buffers for things that
are
shared across draw calls so stuff like
the environment the camera
that kind of stuff which is why again
the push constants are just like i am
i am rendering a sphere i need stuff
that is specific to that sphere such as
the position of the sphere
the which is like the the major the
transform matrix
the color of the sphere the roughness of
the sphere if it's not using a texture
you know that kind of stuff
um all right i think that that is pretty
much
it um
what else can i say really yeah so
so long story short that this process
right now which
i've over the months i've kind of
this is what hazel does in haiti sorry
in hazel dev
um this is this seems pretty good
to me it's a bit annoying that we first
have to compile vulcan before we get to
opengl
but it shouldn't be that much of a
problem because of course shaders only
need to be compiled
when they're changed um which is not
that common
um outside of developing the engine
right so if you're like
creating if you're actually creating a
new shader and you're working on a
shader
um and you're working in opengl yeah
you'll have to be
creating you'll have to be compiling
your shader into spurvi vulcan
and then cross compiling it into spurvy
opengl
um i don't really think there's a
problem with that because you have to
write your shader in in vulcan glsl
because otherwise
what are we doing like you can't i don't
want to write my shader twice
and obviously opengl spervy oh sorry
opengl jr cells are compatible with
block
so um that's basically i think the story
of materials and everything we need to
do inside
hazel dev so again what i'm thinking
about now sorry inside hazel and inside
the game engine series so what i'm
thinking about for now right
is um if we are going to eventually use
vulcan
which i mean we are right
if we are eventually going to use vulcan
then
why would we waste time doing stuff like
gl
active uniform and trying to retrieve
uniforms from opengl
if we're going to no longer have
uniforms written
anymore right um i think it would be
better to embrace
vulcan and embrace spur v and just do
that immediately
even though again technically speaking
right um even though technically
speaking
uh it would be way more work and
we could get away without using vulcan
at all for the next year or whatever in
but since i know that the series is
going to eventually head into balkan i
feel like we should be vulcan friendly
and we should already kind of go go to
this route which again
very much so means that whilst we might
not actually add vulcan in the next year
or so in the in the game engine series
our shaders will actually be vulcan
shaders which is going to be fun we'll
be using
we'll be using things like push
consonants but then not actually because
it gets compiled into something else
um wish the other way around is easier i
have to adapt a ton of opengl shaders to
can at work um well yeah i mean
obviously you know when you a new
technology comes out and then you have
to embrace
and adapt to the new technology not to
the old one
that's how life works
can't use push constants with textures
well no you don't use push consoles
actually um
uh textures are very different
textures are just things that you um set
up like bindings to
binding points okay
so that that's basically what we're
going to do i think
um which basically means that we need to
uh sort out spur v um
and sperry reflect uh and shadow c
and a whole bunch of other libraries
which i already have worked through
um there's a lot of stuff there